what we're trying to do is we're trying
to deliver on the holy grail of the crm
promise right so people tell you about
you have the local grocer that you you
know as a kid you used to go down yep
and he's like hey you know the new
suites that you like just came in
because he knows you he knows you by
name he said you know we congratulate
you about the new haircut that you just
got but you're super happy right you're
getting this amazing
personalized experience because you have
an intimate relationship with that kind
of like joe the grocer right yes
essentially this is what big brands have
been trying to do for the past you know
30 years
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillary stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders i am joined today by pina cowell
the founder and ceo of optimove a
provider of the leading crm marketing
platform
pini's extensive experience in analytics
driven marketing business consulting and
sales along with his innovative
approaches to entrepreneurship and
business building have earned him
recognition as a thought leader pina has
led up to move to become a market leader
with hundreds of brands using his
company's software and services to
orchestrate and automate highly
effective personalized crm
preniaque welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you thanks for having me no
thank you for having me in your
beautiful offices at optimove
i'm really excited to dig into your
founders journey and and your own
experience today a market leader with
hundreds of brands working with optimove
to try and understand their customers
customer journeys better in the digital
world where the consumers have so many
ways to interact with brands and and and
you just lose sight of what's happening
and and where we're at so before we even
get to that
tell me a little bit about where you're
where you came from because you really
embody the the idea of an entrepreneur
what has your journey been like so far
sure so my journey basically started
university i
was
doing a master's degree in stochastic
modeling
in tel aviv and i was on my way to do a
phd but decided that i want to work with
people
and
and yeah and basically i started
optimove mostly as a business
with
a friend from university
and we essentially started as a kind of
like a data agency we just interacted
with israeli companies at the time
uh you know israeli banks israeli
retailers just kind of like you know
sold them some some data work that we
did on their data everything was manual
we charge retainers and that was the
beginning you say business and you chose
the word business and not a startup what
what is the distinction that you're that
you chose here because for me at least
kind of like when i got started it was
everything was about discovery right it
was my first job out of university i
didn't know anything so it was i wanted
to kind of like
you know get in touch with the surface
and
just meet customers learn about the
problems everything was completely new
for me i did meet some vcs at the time
but like i didn't understand them they
didn't understand me today in hindsight
i get it but i wasn't ready for that so
i felt like i just want to work you know
work with customers uh service them see
their problems
and that's basically what started mobius
right that that was the name of the data
agency and we did that for three years
uh up to 2012 and then 2012 we actually
became a software company we pivoted
from service to software became a sas
company which is called optimum so so
walk me through that that intersection
when you because usually when when when
comp when organizations do that from my
understanding it's usually when they
understand that there is a bigger
problem to solve at scale and now
software is going to help them do a lot
of the manual processes on a retainer
for example what was that moment like
for you right so for us it wasn't it
wasn't like you know a founder looking
for a plot a big problem then trying to
solve it it was more like a founder that
did something at university we had this
specific modeling technique that we knew
very well
and we we said something like hey you
know data mining is really cool and i
guess it was very naive right there
wasn't like a deep market analysis or
something like that
so and we asked ourselves questions like
is segmentation a product
like is predicting you know future value
of a customer is that a product right we
asked a lot of questions like what's a
product
so we had this modeling technique even
at the agency days and we always knew
that we're going to be a software
company right it was always the goal
it's not i think a lot of people when
they set up an agency the problem is
that agency becomes very successful and
makes a lot of money very fast
we didn't do that right we now why is
that a problem because then they were
just on the linear growth no because
they're then they're hooked you know the
ability to to pivot to become a software
business it's very hard right because it
kind of like it becomes ingrained in
your dna you become a service person
right you become an agency guy
so
for us a agency was kind of like a the
data agency was kind of like
you know somebody's bartending at night
attempting but eventually you know you
want to be a doctor right so you're just
funding med school
so that was like it was a means to an
end it was always a part of the vision
so
essentially what happened because we had
this customer modeling technique you
know we had to build a single customer
view just to to predict on the data
and
it all became connected with you know
with crm marketing retention marketing
at that time still the world was very
much focused on acquisition marketing i
think fast forward into today
you know you're seeing many brands kind
of like being frustrated with how much
you're paying you know facebook or
google
and sometimes they re-buy the same
customers again and again and again so
now kind of like everybody understands
that investing in your existing
customers
is a
is amazing is an amazing growth engine
because not only
it's important and it's it's much more
cost effective also what it does
it becomes another acquisition channel
because you get a viral loop happy
customers tell the customers so then you
get more customers
but it came from it didn't come from
you know just kind of like oh this is
what we can do you know let's see the
data that brands have
we can we can come up with cool insights
and then the products start becoming
kind of like this this
inside discovery about customer data and
then later on in our second pivot
we've added campaign orchestration to
actually action this data okay
this makes sense 100 now today fast
forward your
employees around
uh international right
and you're you've bootstrapped up until
about i guess 2016 you mentioned right
so 2016 we raised the where's the first
round of funding from igp we took 20
million and
yeah that that was now as as as the
entrepreneur at that moment so you
understand that you're transitioning to
a software-based solution a sas product
you're understanding that you're going
to you're going to be selling to
to a massive array of companies right
there's going to be a lot of different
companies that are that are potential
buyers of this the growth that you can
experience
can be like a hockey stick growth of a
traditional startup but you don't go on
the traditional startup
trajectory
is that intentional i think yeah it was
intention
i think you know the
you know the the agency days kind of
like created this culture for me that
you know
i got to get my own money right so i get
my money from customers and then
what i did back at the engine i also
invested back
you know in
carving the path to become a software
business so the culture it created it
was very simple right
um this is your monthly revenue right
and this is your monthly spend and
there's a gap here right if the gap is
big enough and i feel comfortable with
it i invested in the next bottleneck
right for example marketing is
right so i take this money i reinforce
marketing
a month later two months later you
signed two three more clients this is
the gap right and on the side you have a
cash buffer right which is supposed to
sustain shocks right if you have a
mistake or you have a big churn or
something like that that's how i did it
all the time right when i got to the
software part
this culture was already part of how i
operated
and we were pretty lucky or
fortunate or i don't know what but what
happened at the time when we started our
software
israel had no e-commerce no digital
nothing right right what was very strong
here is this 2012 we're talking about
2012 wow but still you had gaming here
you had 888 and playtech which is kind
of like two gaming pioneers coming out
of israel
which created a lot of a
you know gaming scene here in israel and
also in europe so what happens was when
i first met the gaming guys
they loved kind of like the idea of
lifetime value prediction they like they
loved the idea of micro segmentation
about you know orchestrating campaigns
and messages in a smarter way
so
long story short we became kind of like
we we started to monopolize the gaming
industry so they were like this is what
i want and then we got a ton of clients
via word of mouth
and we got a you know it started from
very small gaming operators went up to
bigger midsize and and today some of the
biggest ones in the world
and that created also a very healthy
business from a financial perspective so
in my mind i always had enough to invest
in what i wanted so i never felt
like a deficiency of cash or something i
i always felt like you know up till the
point that i raised money
which still at that point were like very
profitable i didn't have to do it right
it wasn't it wasn't so why great
question um
it's it's i always i always joke around
and say like in the i don't know if you
know the flight of the concord but like
conditions were perfect
so in a way
you know
you know when you do the bootstrapping
route you always look at the other side
and look at people that do the vc route
and you know it's quite lonely the
bootstrapping route you you at some
point you want a little bit of
validation
you want maybe a little bit of the
comfort of the cash that's going to
protect you in case something bad
happens
uh you're thinking of acquisitions m a
things you'll be able to do and just
kind of like it flowed very nicely and i
felt that you know
igp is going to be able to help
so so that's why i did it but i could
easily not do it now as you're growing
the company as you're growing a culture
and i'm guessing that the culture that
you mentioned this bootstrapping culture
of of of first getting the customers
creating value and then from the excess
value that you created injecting and
integrating even more value
how does that resonate with it with the
rest of the with the rest of the supply
chain within the company because they're
because they're watching the israeli
ecosystem you know raising a ton of
money
it's a different environment right right
so i think i think it's
especially today right when you when
you're speaking now in 2021
post covid i think this is the the
highest extreme like i've never seen it
like that right right it's always been
the case for me i've always i've always
been in a situation where kind of like
other other companies are kind of like
raising more money and things like that
excuse me
but today is like really hyped up
and
it's i think i think you basically you
you're very frank with employees right
you say look we run we run a profitable
shop right it's different
uh we're not spending other people's
money
and
you give them a lot of other things like
we promote a lot from within so
two-thirds of our mid-management and
management came from within the company
wow
so which at some point can also have
problems right we can talk about it
later but uh
so yeah so we invest a lot in young
talent and
kind of like nurture that young talent
to into better positions which is also
something that creates it's mutually
beneficial to both parties but yeah it's
it's always a struggle right and i think
eventually you know people choose well
to go to work by a certain set of
criteria
and
you know there's always been companies
that pay more right if that's your
optimization function then
right so so every so far it sounds
perfect it sounds like you started you
started a date agency you found a really
big pain point you transitioned into a
software you're growing it today you're
on 260 employees and it's growing
beautifully
where where's the poop what what what's
what's so hard then about building the
business here in general today or or for
your time
um i think i think you go through like
those different stages of scale i think
that kind of like when i you know it's
it's been like a
you know a nine year almost a ten
ten-year journey for me
and i'm
i'm a very analytical person uh right
being kind of like with an analytics
company
and i think
it's funny like for the first few years
i felt like with myself that i've made
no mistakes
and
because it's funny in this type of a
journey especially when you do something
very well at the beginning
you're going to be propelled by inertia
you know very strongly upwards for a
while right
when you do make those when you do make
mistakes sometimes it takes two three
four years to see them in in actuality
in reality well
and that's a big difficulty right
because usually you know we as people
we're trained like our feedback loop
is shorter right we're not yes
especially think about people that go in
between many many jobs they don't even
see kind of like the mistake that
they've made
yeah i see everything right because i
gave birth to the thing right
and i'm still here so
i have this journey and i think at some
points like you started seeing like when
you get to a certain scale obviously
it's a cliche right the things that work
that this and that size are going to
break
you know at the 2 3 4 x size
and then and then i saw some of those
things kind of like breaking and you
know i started to to go back and realize
that
i think the same things like the same
traits in me
that
make me the perfect entrepreneur for
bootstrapping
are the same traits that eventually
you know made me take decisions that
created problems at a certain scale okay
and what i've been doing in the last two
years is basically releasing a new
version of myself
that will
adapt and how do you ask how do you ask
those difficult questions is this
something that you're able to do
personally do you have a court of people
that you're asking them to mirror you oh
yeah look i'm i'm a blabber mouth right
if i'll meet you at a party you know
i'll you know i'll
i'll talk to you about some things and
and i'll be open about my things
and yeah and obviously you know i do a
ton of introspection
um
all the time right what you're trying to
do is you try to hack reality right
you're trying to understand what's
happening to you why it's happening to
you if it's good you get too vain and
you think that kind of like all of your
decisions are kind of like given uh
merits
and when it's bad uh you start to kind
of like beat yourself up and try to
understand what is it that you and
sometimes a lot of things are not in
your control right the market goes a
certain way like we're talking a lot
about the fact that we
you know some of our data technologies
we've chosen
uh weren't the right ones but like when
you go back to 2012 you know the cloud
wasn't there yet like you had no
snowflake
you had like hadoop and stuff like that
and i'm lucky i didn't go there
so
it's always in hindsight you know
sometimes things look like oh i could
have done this and that but definitely i
have some some major takeaways tell me a
little bit about where we're at today in
terms of
you know brands customer journeys
understanding what what's happening with
with the digital interactions of our
customers where are we today with 2021
yeah so uh
we so
let's back up a little bit what we're
trying to do is we're trying to deliver
on the holy grail of the crm promise
right so people tell you about
you have the local grocer that you you
know as a kid you used to go down yep
and he's like hey you know the new
sweets that you like just came in
because he knows you he knows you by
name he said you know he congratulate
you about the new haircut that you just
got yes and you even kind of like you
say you know write it on my books yes
you're not even paying because you have
this relationship and then your dad pays
once a month
and what did you buy all this for
but you're super happy right you're
getting this amazing
personalized experience because you have
an intimate relationship with that kind
of like joe the grocer right yes
essentially this is what big brands have
been trying to do for the past you know
30 years right since the beginning of
crm
i think crm has a lot of different
meanings you know in in b2b companies it
means the software for sales people
which is not what i'm talking about
right i'm talking about kind of like
real customer relationships the
relationship relationship right so the
relationship means that
so if you're looking at the relationship
that you had as a kid with joe the
grocer what we're trying to do
is say
if i'm a big fashion brand and you know
and customers buy products because they
like my design and my style and the
price point and everything
now the relationship comes in right now
marketing comes in so
when i'm speaking to these customers as
a brand
am i being emotionally intelligent right
am i being um
you know when i communicate with them
first of all do i know them oh i'm just
kind of like sending this this ban this
template that this like you know
mass market banner that you can see on
tv or on the billboard
with digital
you can get to know them right because
you see everybody's data right
you see what they bought from you and
the transactional data you see the
behavioral data everything they're doing
the website the mobile app you can get
some data from other places so then you
can create a single customer view
and then same thing as kind of like joe
would say hey you know your favorite
suite just came in
i can say it
via email or push or in the facebook ad
or whatever right so i can so the whole
point is kind of like chasing this
experience and i think today
when i started it was harder to deliver
we still did that very nicely but not on
all the channels
and you know
not at the same scale of data i think
not with the same level of
sophistication of machine learning and
ai that today we can really get to know
you again based on the limited data that
we have
so that's what we do
and so as you're looking at brands
why why what is so difficult for them to
do to do this internally so they have
marketers they have analytics right they
they know what's happening sort of maybe
not really but but what is sort of the
big breakthrough that optimove is
bringing to these digital brands so
first of all there's a lot of
there's a big marketing ops endeavor
right at play so if you think about what
you need to do to to run a campaign just
like we said right you need to
to analyze the data so first you need
the data to be there right all the data
in one place
if you have to chase five different
silos of data to stitch them together
and come up with one analysis and do one
campaign a month went by and you did one
right so the question is
how can you scale personalization so
that's what we we say all the time
you know those campaigns those
communications work very very well
because you as a consumer you appreciate
the relevancy
you're saying hey you know that's a
really smart brand you reward the brand
with your loyalty
but now when the brand's trying to scale
that thing right so you got as i said
you got the data part you know data is
messed up you have to bring it together
create a single customer view so that
the marketer like a 25 year old marketer
that's doing crm can go boom boom boom
boom i found an amazing audience oh i
can see that this audience is predicted
to do this and that this is what they
like i have an idea this is what i'm
going to do
from the moment you have an idea now you
want to execute that
how do you go about it right so
wait so now i need to do it over email
or over facebook if it's over facebook i
gotta speak to the ad team because
there's me there's like budgets and
stuff like that and bids and okay if
it's over email so there's another
speciality about email i need to create
an html template or something i need to
there's a bit of code that goes into
that then it's just one part of the
journey but what happens if that person
gets that thing and buys what they want
to say then or what happens if they
don't buy
what happens if they don't respond to
email do i talk to them over sms do i do
something or
so and there's just one and a million
more permutations for everybody and a
million more permutations so you need
the machine learning for the
permutations then you need a team of of
the users that kind of like know how to
project manage that thing yes they
understand the channels they understand
data a little bit
so i think if you want to do it like
so what we do with our customers our
best customers we do hundreds of these
every week
hundreds and hundreds so that's our
claim to thing right we are the only
solution that will allow you to scale
personalization
there's many solutions you can do
automation a lot of solutions that we
will do rule-based automation right so
there's a journey you just draw it up if
this happens that happens if this
happens that happens fine when you have
hundreds of these it starts to cause
fire it becomes a huge mess you don't
know what's working it's really hard to
attribute the value of each thing you're
doing so that this idea of
incrementality
so that that's what we do best but
essentially for brands to answer your
question it's hard right it's a lot of
work you need
you need a lot of systems a lot of
automation a lot of data capability
changes
capabilities it changes all the time so
people who do it well even with like a a
two-person team or or like a 40-person
team
it's extremely rewarding
i love it and you know opinion i think i
feel like we're just getting started but
i've personally learned so much both
from your own journey but also from the
domain that you're in and and obviously
you know we're living in a personalized
world and personalization at scale and
it's amazing i do have three more
questions about you though not about
okay moving about the domain take me
back to your childhood
curiosity what really fascinated you as
a kid
you mentioned you're a philosopher now
but what really fascinated you as a kid
yeah to
i i think i was i was you know
but i do have a funny story like when i
was a i was born in 78 so when i was 6
my dad decided that computers is the
future
so wow he bought me like this this uh
you know ibm look-alike machine like
toymibm right not the actual ibm
and he was like here's a computer and
and there was a few uh you know
for sure number like books of how to
learn to program basic
and he sat down with me and we did the
first program and i coded something in
basic
so i was like that's amazing then i
closed the computer i put we had some
nylons that you put on top of it right
so it's not gonna get dusty
and the next one i opened it i was 17.
wow so yeah so like
my dad was right but i never learned how
to code i love it yeah i wasn't uh
amazing so maybe giving you the
anti-answer to what you asked for but
i'll take it what inspires you today
something and maybe an event or
something i'm going i think yeah i think
for me kind of like what inspires me is
is uh
you know
let's call it
um you know this idea of discovery i
think that kind of like uh
even self-discovery i think that yeah
that's probably the thing that i
enjoy the most or what i find to be the
essence of living
is this notion of self-discovery right
so and this is what the company gave me
right as an entrepreneur
i can discover what's marketing i can
discover how it feels like to write to
write a blog and be like a you know a
journalist right i can discover what
it's like to
to do architectural technology you know
so you get this this
this benefit of kind of like being the
little the modern age lonado da vinci
of your own little pond right
and in general you know this process of
you know
succeeding making mistakes fixing your
mistakes you know
that's the definition of freedom right
being able to fix your own mistakes so
for me it's it's self-discovery and kind
of like trying to get to know myself
better
where can i thrive
what do i like
and i think that that's that's our job
in life right until we we get to a
certain point that we're like well done
i love it and what are the three words
you would use to describe yourself
yeah so i i said this once in another i
think it's it's nice and it sends some
kind of a message so i would say bigger
than my genetics
i love it penny today thank you very
very much best of luck with optimove
thank you thank you for sharing your
journey
[Music]